la faccenda si fa molto interessante
stia funzionando nove volte si riduce a
un di sacco di cose botte un sacco di
cose poco dignitose terzo dove per fare
di soluzioni top ove necessario
[Musica]
no non credo di sapere cosa devo fare
quando volevo fare ragazzi ci siamo
spinti oltre tutto la bertè arenò però
in arriverà mai in questo momento della
mia mano l'inerzia conoscere pannolini
conoscete un cristiano fatta kaká
cristiano fatti ci provo christian patto
che cingono il territorio il pannolino
oggi spiegare come funzionava il
pannolino vannino funzionale che finale
sotto ciapetti bambini najat a torre non
avere figli esserci un motivo per
chiudere al pannolino e fanno velo
trattenere sostanze che pompino piace
piace sostanza che trattiene pannolino
piace almeno fricka dobbiamo alzare il
culetto state fermi star ma quando
christian che aiuta dottor al sequestro
operato
inserire pannolino dottore dottore
parente modello dottore si cambiava da
solo pannolini quando età di criteri si
ora campi a parte siamo 4 fa esperimento
perché dottore ha mosso per questo
pannolino avere proprietà incredibile
vedere questa polverina polverina
ricavata da parlino perché se noi si
stende propone una volta tagliato il
padrino bisogna tirarla più pazza e
vedere che all'interno di pannolino
essere usciti col brivido come
cacciatore aver messo da parte nel sacco
di polverina prima di tutto pronto per
il polverino di pannolino all'interno di
caraffa caraffa di pizza e diventare
magica perché noi blender
acqua e versare in guai se noi versiamo
acqua in brocca di polvere noi otteniamo
ma ciro bisogna mescolare acqua di
blatter mescolare più lentamente magari
[Musica]
[Applauso]
una volta mescolata acqua di blocca la
magia può avere effetto perché noi
prendere la caraffa utilizzata conta 35
in pascoe fa cioè fiat carlton e noi
cira
[Musica]
rcd
allora non scendere perché essa magica
acqua non scendere mai ho necessità di
mostrare scendere a quale sono veramente
troppo magica un po meno dottore
spazientito
[Musica]
ma che è arreso ma può essere diventata
materiale per palline magiche
rimbalzanti dopo aver creato neve
artificiale non capirebbero funzionare
le necessità di lavare le mani quindi un
tetto di esperimento contento di aver
familiarizzato con fantini lori civile
speriamo che episodio piaciuto a essere
i priori che mettono mi piace a tutti i
detenuti più dare appuntamento al
prossimo episodio
datemi la madrina grazie
[Musica]